[Music]
[Music]
scott landon
doesn't talk a lot about his childhood
to anybody
and at the same time all his books and
stories
draw from that childhood
he grew up in the home of a dangerous
abusive parent
[Music]
scotland had a very very painful
troubled past
and how to go to buy a moon to heal
[Music]
it's this sort of unbelievable epic
place
it's almost like a physical landscape of
the subconscious
and it's a place that i used to go and
both draw inspiration and heal myself
when you play a scot london when you
play a rider that is somehow
like stephen king you have to carry on
that
internal world that a writer has because
you always wonder
how is it when they spend hours and
hours just by themselves
in front of a computer just creating it
becomes so interesting private and i
think
clive has that cliff is a brilliant
brilliant actor
you can totally feel and believe that he
has the internal world
of a writer
mr dooley it's lizzy landon
you win i'll give you whatever you want
meet me here at 10 p.m
i won't call the police but please just
don't hurt me
don't hurt me anymore
that was good no no none of this is good
you